good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy monday today's
episode is brought to you by betterhelp
it doesn't matter who you are or what
you have life can be pretty damn hard
and without a healthy mind it's even
harder check out online therapy with
betterhelp.com toast and be on your way
to a little more ease welcome back to
the morning toast welcome welcome
welcome welcome welcome welcome welcome
welcome welcome welcome to the morning
toast i mean we were only missing for
one day it feels like an eternity it
does feel like an eternity it's been so
long since i saw you how was your trip
thank you for asking
i mean i couldn't start on any other
foot like the k sized elephant in the
room my trip was incredible like a teeny
tiny elephant it was so
meaningful like it really was
true
downtime quality time with kay flew in
thursday
excuse me
stayed till sunday and it was just
kkk spending the entire weekend with my
gorgeous beautiful precious angel niece
kaler um she's gotten so big since we've
last seen her like it's disgusting
um it's actually offensive how like the
nerve she has to grow without us yeah
and
it was amazing but it was also like
really sad like the whole time there was
this like cloud at least for me
over the weekend knowing like i'm gonna
have to say goodbye to olivia and to
kayla you know in 24 hours and 36 hours
so that was really hard it was really
i'm not gonna lie like it wasn't all
sunshine in florida like it was
there were some clouds cover me in
sunshine it was cloudy like for sure
damn but you did it i did it we had an
amazing time liv's house looks so good
she of course said you know when the
time is right she's here for a home tour
on the patreon so you guys knew that
though she wanted me to re reiterate to
everyone she misses you thank you all
for all the wonderful messages you've
been sending her helpful tips on you
know how to stay cool in florida how to
get lizards out of your house okay we
ordered betty hanna and i opened the
door and literally the biggest lizard
ran through the door and i went
screaming through the house like it's
just florida tings florida tings but i
actually have a soft spot in my heart
for lizards because your sister is one
because i believe that margot audrey is
a lizard reincarnated and so when i see
a lizard i send a lizard yeah and it
makes me feel like margo's with me
wherever i am so if you look at it that
way how fun margo joined the weekend no
i don't know
i don't look at it that way at all it
was [ __ ] traumatizing but you know i
swam i got so unbelievably sunburned and
i only laid out for one day which is
just fabulous did you wear sunscreen no
but it was one day in florida like i'm
not at the equator i'm in florida it was
late september early october right
still so
things fall i guess i'm like my chest is
bright [ __ ] red that's exciting yeah
because i'm going on a major trip this
week and i was like didn't want to be
pale and i hate getting a spray tan
before a trip because i can't swim oh i
love getting a spray tan before a trip
then i can't really be myself you know
like oh yeah you know it limits your
mobility well you can swim just not in
the chlorine pool so you just have to
make sure everything's you know
saltwater oh i'll be showing up to
someone's house is this a chlorine-based
pool you just gotta ask the hard
questions also you don't want to get in
a chlorine pool because
it'll chip your nail polish too then you
can get a massage like it really limits
the things you can do on a vacation you
can't yeah you can't do those things
like day one two or maybe three but then
after that you can do those things so i
guess now would be a good time to tell
you guys that we are off okay so here's
the schedule shows monday tuesday and
they're going to be amazing amazing
shows we're in one now and i think it's
going really well i think so too and i
also need to share the content i consume
this weekend because i listened to so
many podcasts because we were driving so
much like i listened to so much joe
rogan and i have so many thoughts i
listened to amanda knox on joe rogan you
know amanda
i didn't know he was
wait what
i know she's doing podcasts now not only
is she doing joe rogan she has her own
podcast she explained and it sounds like
really premium so i'm not going to lie
i'm not the type of person who's into
like murders like i don't really some
people like spend all their time
thinking about who killed john and like
i don't even know who's suspicious in
the case um so did amanda knox do it no
no okay well i'm you know everybody has
their opinions but like when you're
listening to this episode it's like
there's no did she didn't she it's like
she was completely wrong with really
convicted and now she really spends her
life dedicated to like helping those who
are wrongfully conducting like the
innocence project and stuff like that so
it's not so much like a murder mystery
it's more so like justice needs to be
served podcast oh i didn't know that
yeah so interesting but anyways back to
the schedule monday tuesday we're here
and we're amazing and we're amazing for
you wednesday thursday friday we are off
because claudia is going on a vacation
and you know what she deserves it
because she's really been like picking
up pregnancy slack wow thank you she
deserves a vacation and i'm really
excited for you to take that break me
too i just absolutely love traveling
with brian like it's gonna i mean ben's
coming too and i'm excited of course
the rebel tigs but like the first two
days i'm like spending with brian and
we're just like the best time even
though there's severe weather storms
like where we're going but
it'll be an adventure then monday we are
off because it's the holiday and tuesday
we will be podcasting together
not in studio no but we will have a
podcast episode and then i didn't even
tell you this
wednesday
special project big announcement i think
it might behoove you guys to become
patreon members on wednesday that's all
i'll say but it'd actually help you
become patreon members sooner because we
will have content there to get you
through the week where we are yes off so
we're back on podcast tuesday back in
studio wednesday yeah
so
i think i feel really good about it and
you know what i could use the extra z's
no i know and to be honest like i really
took this trip because i knew you were
pregnant and i knew you could use some
time off i didn't want you to feel
guilty for asking like you know i'm not
feeling great like can i take a day off
this way i did it for you thank you so
much so i look like the lazy one when
it's actually you you know except you're
like airing me out right here it's
completely me i took the trip because
i'm so [ __ ] excited to get out of
town i too consumed a lot of content
this weekend um i watched snl the
premiere
i watched squid games have you heard
about squid games
i heard about it i feel like zach would
like it you might like it um i mean
aliyah watched it and then i finished it
on the plane and
it was good okay
like the end was so bad that like i feel
like i wasted my time but i was really
enjoying it up until then and like just
a different kind of show i feel like i
watched the same iteration of every show
like everything i watch is the same yeah
it was nice to feel something different
yeah that is nice um and of course i
watched moana
and i watched shrek you're not hanging
with kay if you're not watching moana no
we watched moana so many times and then
i was like olivia please put on
something else no and those songs start
to live in your head run free and it's
not even how far i'll go it's like the
one
the opening song what can i say except
you're welcome
and then i was like please please put on
something else we watch shrek too
because olivia is not even mckayla
doesn't even like it like olivia's
obsessed with that scene at the end here
i need a hero and i'm not gonna lie it
was pretty fire so
it was a real medley of content we'll
dive into it in the tv recap and i did
watch real housewives of salt lake city
and potomac which i know you didn't and
normally i would let you slide but like
we i need to tell you that's what
happened like both episodes were
fabulous no i was reading last night
because we are recording our new episode
of the redheads today the book we read
is a slow fire burning by paula hawkins
she's the same author who wrote girl on
the train you ever see that movie emily
blunt oh yeah i didn't see the movie but
i read the book this is our first
thriller crazy on the train it was my
choice and so i needed to like just
power read all night and that left no
time for watching tv i'm sorry but you
know my redhead duties i will not
forsake them you know how important this
passion is to me how was your weekend i
heard you had a fall
fall fiesta an autumnal outage was full
of fall i went to vermont with my
friends and brew did you
fall into full i fell hard i fell
hard
is the baby okay everything is falling
so hard okay yeah no because all the
leaves caught me
um it was really like i think so i think
next weekend fall is really so short
it's crazy because also like the leaves
are changing they're on their way to
death
yeah no so like the prime leaves it's
really only two three weeks so i think
next weekend is probably perfect fall
leaves but like they were a change and
so we had some green we had some orange
red yellow so it was nice the best we
did get to see the leaves changing and
on the drive up there was some leaves
changing and on the drive back
they had changed so much in the two days
we were gone
that's how crazy that's how fast it
happens wow yes you got to keep your
eyes open so brew had never really
experienced faultings because um brew
came into our lives in late october
so
he just had an amazing weekend as did i
was so nice to be with friends be
outside get some fresh air
sit around the fireplace we made a chili
and by we you know it was me i'm just
gonna let everyone head chef head chef
on the chili everyone like did their
part for other things but i was on chili
patrol and there was not a bite left not
a such a good feeling i've never
experienced such a good feeling everyone
was talking about how like the heat was
perfect i got a little spicy i was
worried about my heartburn but like
thank god it wasn't that bad um and it
was just
uh chili season is here you guys i had
to i ordered meat because um i brought
the meat with me so that we i could eat
meat all weekend and now i have like
meat at home and so i'll be
chillified for the next few months and
you found a recipe that works for you i
did it i used half baked harvests white
bean turkey chili which
was so good i've made it twice now so
easy
but i think you know i'm going to look
for like a beef i have ground beef now
in my freezer so can you just do the
same recipe and swap the turkey for beef
yeah but
i'm extremely
i follow the recipes to a tea that's how
i know they'll come out good so i don't
start add a living yeah and that's the
kind of cook i am can i totally switch
gears really quickly sure um not that
your chili isn't
so interesting and it is number one
topic of the day no it is but you know
what was the number one topic of the
weekend if in like the digital
influencer space and i just want to talk
about it because the influencer you know
champagne and chanel
yeah she's a toaster and so i started
following her because she was listening
to the toes and i'm like oh she's
fabulous like let's see what you got
going on she got married okay i saw
something about this it was
literally gorgeous like i feel like this
many people haven't followed a wedding
like literally since you're right oh my
god i'm on my way jackie it was so
setting i don't know if her stories are
still up because it was on saturday no
but maybe she has like a carousel or
something you know what
i feel like i loved the way that i don't
she obviously wasn't running her
instagram for the day maybe like an
assistant was i loved the way she just
like seamlessly was keeping us all
updated in real time from the rehearsal
dinner to the uh the morning of getting
everyone getting their makeup done the
ceremony like we saw it all in real time
there were so many other influencers
there so there was so much premium
content i think she got married in
austin texas yes i believe that she did
and it was she looked gorgeous like
you'd love to see a toaster throw wow so
beautiful out there story she has a
highlight ten two twenty one oh yeah so
wait until you get to the actual party
like the whole tent was made out of
lights that's the um
ceremony stunning and then this outdoor
like clear tent that was like just
literally like a snowblower like lit up
with with like twinkle lights it was
just gorgeous oh my god that's amazing
okay i look forward to consuming this
like if you're looking for something to
do and you're bored like check out this
wedding champagne chanel and she's a
toaster and it was just like gorgeous
that's so exciting i can't remember the
last time i was like living by carrie
sleeping through her wedding event same
she's just like this gorgeous girl and
toaster
and she's a she's hysterical everything
in the source amazing taste beautiful
setting spark
yeah it's so hard to find people like
that these days no it is but when you
find them
you got to keep them yeah um so yeah
that was part of the content that i
consumed but i'm really um happy to be
back i missed you i missed you too you
know what else i can taylor missed you
oh don't i can't even talk about it i
just can't like i just have to move on
um what else i consumed before i left
for my trip on thursday night i watched
what to expect when you're expecting oh
wow
and i've seen it before yeah but
watching it pregnant i was just like
so which one do you think you are so
i'm not anyone in particular and i do
think that even though elizabeth banks
is meant to be like the mess like she
still
is quite put together right right she's
a smelly farts like yeah no but i'm the
like i know i will be the elizabeth like
i think there's tougher like she still
only had like a belly yeah right what
about the arms right right everything
else so
it was interesting i really didn't feel
like i was any of them
but i was really enjoying it made me
emotional at the end you know when they
all get their babies so i was i really
really enjoyed it if you're pregnant i
would recommend watching it because it
just gets you like excited and and just
in your feels okay good
um so i feel like i'm all caught up
pretty much it was kayla kayla kayler a
little bit of kaler and then at the end
i saw some kayla so
but did you get any kaler i did you know
what and i changed her diaper like she
was making the biggest duties i feel
like you know she's eating good in
florida she's exercising she like
literally when she was living in new
york she never left her apartment she
had a blister on her big toe because
she's just like constantly doing the
work she's doing the most i bought her
her first bike i like wanted to make you
know be like a fun auntie yeah the
auntie who spoils her so i got an
amazing bike that will last her till
she's five years old and you like have
to change it every year like right now
she's obviously not using the pedals so
it has like something for her to lay her
feet on olivia pushes her so it's like a
stroller but then it evolves into like a
real bike when you're five that's so
exciting yeah and she was just such a
good [ __ ] girl everywhere she went
queen [ __ ] yeah queen [ __ ] okay i need
to i don't want to get bogged down you
know
so without further ado it is time for
the past five stories that you need to
know before you wake up and take a bite
out of your morning toes
that's true for sure um but i don't know
if you could smell my breath from here
but it's so delightfully delicious
thanks to my bruce the best electric
toothbrush on the market and today's
sponsor if you are looking to switch
over to an electric toothbrush but
you're a little trepidatious because
some of them can cost over 200 which is
absolutely insane check out the bruce it
is in my opinion the best one the most
affordable one and the most gorgeous one
hands down like that's a fact so they
have a brush that comes with six unique
modes that customize your brushing
experience their battery life lasts four
weeks of on a brush and it comes with a
magnetic charging stand and a compact
travel case they also now offer a
subscription program so never forget to
change your brush head again they will
ship you a new replacement head every
six months so you're never stuck using a
worn down brush head their design is
very sleek they drop new colors a couple
times a year it's like the biggest drop
of the season i just got a new one it's
like a hunter green it's everything of
the sort and
you ain't living unless you're bushing
so if you've been wanting to switch to
electric toothbrush this is your sign
because this is the official toothbrush
of the morning toast and if you want to
get 15 off your brush toothbrush kit and
the refill plan use promo code toast at
bruce.com toast again that's promo code
toast at
b-r-u-u-s-h dot com slash toast for 15
off thank you claudia yes okay our first
story came out right as we wrapped on
thursday but portia williams confirms
her exit from real housewives of atlanta
after 10 seasons this was shocking yes
so she stated after 10 life-changing
gratifying incredible years it is
finally time to begin my next chapter
next season i will not be returning to
the real house as of atlanta franchise
this was a difficult decision not only
to make but also to come to terms with
it's one i've put a lot of thought into
and because of that i know it's the
right one so i feel like this is
layered as so many things are most
things are first is that this is coming
off the heels of cynthia bailey's a
departure and i feel like when cynthia
left i was like ichi's time you know she
has been you know boring us to tears for
the last like two three seasons and
everything is about like her boyfriend
like it's just not interesting and she
really doesn't get like deep in it
anymore so for me that was kind of like
a natural thing you know with housewives
we shed and we grow but with porsche
this to me signals
not good for i
worry now like based on what i know
that real houses of atlanta might fall
into the same kind of
situation that real housewives of orange
county has found itself in that real
house of new york has found itself in
you know you have so many of the same
women for so many long you're one of the
og franchises and it just gets tired and
i really felt like this last season even
with all the drama on the bachelorette
party polo i still felt like it was so
boring yeah so i don't know i'm worried
i am i would be lying if i said i wasn't
oh then also with porsha there's a lot
of speculation that she's actually
getting her own show oh that's
interesting andy commented like it's
just a pause like
she does have this very interesting life
you know she stole that man
that woman's fiance and now they're
married they're like married in vegas
he's like super super rich she's like
the happiest she's ever been i do think
we could get a porsche spin-off okay
interesting theory because other people
are saying like she probably doesn't
want to talk about her relationship on
the show at this point and maybe like
you know she's the happiest she's ever
been she just has like too much to lose
like bow out now instead of having like
can you bring up your man all the time
and starting these rumors i know but you
know poor's just like really never been
one to back down or like no but like
sometimes in life like when it's just
you and you're defending yourself and
you can take anything but like then when
you have like people behind you that you
love that you want to protect like it
just changes the game and sometimes you
have to say like game over for me you
and it's not even like you're backing
down you're you're growing out of it
yeah that's true so i think her
priorities have changed i mean if she's
getting another show then you know this
is a moot conversation it's like who
would turn that down ever um but if
she's not getting another show it just
might signal that like she's found
something that's worth more to her than
all of the opportunities from the show
yeah well hopefully that would be great
but i do think that there's a
possibility like a tinsel right even
though like that didn't work out it's a
bad example you know real houses of
atlanta has had the most spin-offs i
think
obviously don't be tardy and then they
do so many specials like when nene got
remarried to greg they did a special
candy when she got married got a special
they actually have a lot of success with
their like spin-off type of shows
obviously don't be tardy would be the
most successful with eight seasons but i
don't know i feel like this could be
good if this is what's happening with
porsha yeah
yeah but the show will absolutely suffer
without her whether you're a porsche
lover or porsche hater like you cannot
deny porsha has a broken back from
carrying this show for like five seasons
she's everything of the sort
and now she'll be missed desperately
well the show must go on always curious
to see what they do next but you guys
like it's a really um
it's a really rough time like dark time
as a housewives fan i was actually just
talking about it with my friends i
completely agree i was talking about it
with rebecca who just watches housewives
for fun like for me this is like job
stuff so like it's
and we're like analyzing deep diving
socio
yeah okay you know what i was trying to
say like we're like researchers yeah no
like this is like i don't
just get to like decide oh i'm not gonna
watch uh maybe i'll put it off i'll
batch those episodes next week right we
just watch every night because we're
gonna recap it on the show so like
talking to someone who watches for
pleasure though now it's no longer
really full of pleasure for her is
really interesting and she was having
the same thoughts that i was having of
just like this ain't it and it's a waste
of time it's a waste of brain cells
um
maybe i think for me it's like i'm
changing but also the show is it's not
just like i'm outgrowing housewives it's
like housewives is trash like if it was
good
no housewives is just in this like weird
spot where like
i think that what we're seeing with like
salt lake city and potomac like these
early seasons with girls who are still
hungry for it and who still like
make good tv i don't feel that way about
these newer franchises but i of course
feel that way about like atlanta oc new
york new jersey like i feel like for
sure like they don't the housewives took
off in such an unbelievable way like was
so successful they had this perfect
formula but like so many so much other
reality tv has come and progressed and
changed the game and like housewives is
just still doing the same thing they've
been doing since 2001 and like yeah i
mean i personally like
potomac and salt lake city but rebecca
was saying like she feels this way about
salt lake city too and i was like i
think the aesthetics of salt lake city
though like you know the snow
like that
just helps it's something means
something to me so that helps but like
and potomac is better than some of the
other franchises but even still it's
like a lot of it's just like it's so
formulaic it's 45 minutes of personal
scenes that nobody asked for and then 15
minutes we have a group dinner with a to
be continued like i'm good yes i agree i
do think that they're structured like
when you watch selling sunset or like
bling empire like you see like how the
game has changed like the the way in
which we're making reality tv has
changed so much over the last 10 years
and housewives has not
yeah and they kind of like invented this
space and i do feel like they're getting
left behind like there's no no i don't
think so every i think we're like we're
on the we're pioneers in this thinking
yes yes like they're going to be get
left behind i just i don't know how
people who don't have to watch it
are watching it yeah well i mean when
you think when you look at ratings
from what they used to be and like what
they are now it's crazy but that's also
just like the decline of cable
television yeah but i agree there's
something and i just and this is kind of
my
very sadly like my qualm is that the
right word mm-hmm with andy
like this this is his show this is his
production and like i feel like with
in the last like year or two he just
like doesn't care about like when he
comes to watch him live like he gives it
nothing like and he would say this is
not his show this is not his production
whenever someone comes to him about like
bring back this person or why was this
person fired he will say like he's not
the executive producer well he
he's a talent he maintains that he is
not in charge of casting but like
he is the creative director of these
shows like if he if i i don't think he
thinks that it's as good now as it used
to be right no but i think even if you
said he's the creative director like i
think he he washes his hands of all of
this like he says over and over like
this is not his show this is not my
plate that's what he says yes
that he is he created all of them yes he
did but like now who he is now like we
can't
even say like in the beginning yes it
was him but like now he's just he's a
housewife
paid talent by nbc
yeah well i don't know who's in charge
but like things need to be shaken up
majorly like we can't keep doing the
same thing if you're watching the first
episode of orange county it's very
similar to the most recent one like just
in terms of the structure
so i agree with you and
i actually feel that way about all bravo
shows
because every single bravo show is
structured that way yeah and when
there's just so much reality tv out
there and you're like comparing it
it's not as good yeah
so that's where i'm at i mean
it is what it is there's crazier things
going on in the world than the decline
of housewives no but i do think that
salt lake city potomac and beverly hills
like are still three very good reality
shows like i stand by that like i
watched two hours of housewives last
night and i honestly wasn't even really
on my phone they were like really good
episodes i love all the salt lake city
women and like i love and hate all the
potomac women like i feel like
you're invested yeah okay that's good
our next story taylor swift makes a
shocking reveal about her new red album
taylor swift's newest announcement will
leave fans tickled pink the singer took
to twitter thursday to announce her own
rendition of red will be released a week
early and naturally swifties everywhere
were sent into a frenzy now the
re-release will be out november 12th and
the release will also include the four
disc final according to her tweet so
this is very
on taylor swift of course because
everything is planned to a t 10 years in
advance like this
like she gave us a date she doesn't like
either push the date she doesn't renege
on dave she doesn't wear nag on dates
and the dates are carefully selected
from all the dates in the calendar that
could add up to 13 in some way so here's
what it is adele have you been seeing
adele has been putting up billboards all
over the country with just the number 30
which is going to be her next album okay
adele is coming the album is called
number 30. that's all we have to live
for um and there is a lot of speculation
that it's coming out the weekend that
taylor was planning on releasing red and
you know taylor is like very strict
about getting number one albums and just
like numbers numbers numbers and i don't
think like the two biggest female
artists like were wanting to compete
with each other i guess you know adele
was immovable
therefore taylor was movable you really
think that's what it is yes i mean we'll
see when when we find out when um 30
adele's new album comes out when we find
that out if it's the date that red was
supposed to come out on then we will
know that that is why she changed the
date initially but if adele hadn't
announced her album
date yet whether by not getting pulled
over there's the longest siren that
won't end i was trying to scream over it
it won't end just let it pass like yeah
this too shall pass i hope everyone's
okay
okay
just wait it's right behind us no but we
it's fine it's not a serious
conversation that needs complete silence
i i mean speak for yourself
okay like offending me right to my face
we made our mics it's so [ __ ]
annoying
okay
that was the longest siren of all time
stuck behind our building yeah
traffic traffic traffic okay so let's
get back to the taylor swift adele
sayadel's releasing 30 like she's
looking at the calendar who's releasing
what when like she chose to release the
same day as taylor's read
but i don't think she cares like you
know yeah she's adele this is for adele
it's like this is her
highly highly highly anticipated there's
no way it doesn't go number one divorce
like all of this for
taylor swift she's releasing the album
she's already really singing on songs
she's singing on songs and i'm sure it's
great no slight but like obviously
it doesn't matter but taylor has a lot
of pride in these in these records
because she's going to own them and she
wants them to go number one like they
did the first time like for her it's
like this whole meaningful thing where
adele is just like her big ass come back
and like everyone is going to be like
living for it and who the [ __ ] would
want to compete with that yeah i mean i
just can't believe that that's really
we'll see how things go also like she
could have released it she should have
released it in october it's a fall album
i mean the fact that she literally
announced it in july for november is
just
a wasteland aside from kelly clarkson's
christmas album like
drop it in october give the people what
they want it's [ __ ] twisted
completely agree like i don't know
i just didn't anticipate her dragging
out three records for so long because
she announced
like months ago that it would be the
november
release of red and i'm like so nothing
before that like so if it's like six
months to lead up for six albums it's
gonna take
three years right like please no like
yeah let's
yeah i totally agree but there is like a
lot of speculation about her and the
jonas brothers have you been seeing this
i saw it from the cinch and i'm sorry
but the things that she shared are just
not enough for me okay so
really did you see nick jonas's tick
tock
which one so he like put up a picture
um of like a dumois screenshot which by
the way was fake because jamal was like
i never posted this saying like jonas
brothers x taylor swift pizza emoji and
he was like what what is this what is
this
and then joe has been posting a lot of
the pizza emoji the pizza emoji is
referenced on taylor's mood board it's
referenced in the 22 um music video so a
lot of people think that there's going
to be some sort of jonas brothers
involvement in 22
the song off of red i don't know about
you okay
which i wouldn't understand but i'm if
that's
that would just be crazy that would be
like 2013 all over again
i guess
it's just it's not that deep for me but
i'm overwhelmed but i'm just i'm happy
that it's deep some of us care yeah no
some care immensely and i think that
there's definitely jonas brothers clap
coming this way i do think that the
reason why she moved the album
is because of adele but we'll see okay
and i'm actually
what i've taken away from the story is
i'm hella excited for adele's album it's
just going to be it's going to be
glorious yeah no it it really is and
that's exciting so i got two albums this
year yes yes
exciting thank you for that are you
ready for our next story only if it's
the next story that's brought to you by
modern fertility did you know that a
simple fingerprint can unlock tons of
insight into your reproductive health
we're talking egg count menopause timing
if your hormone levels indicate
conditions like thyroid disorders or
pcos all things that are good to know
whether or not kids are in your future
and that's why modern fertility was
created it's the easy and affordable way
to test your fertility hormones at home
with a single finger prick mail it in
with a prepaid label and you'll get your
personalized results within 10 days
and traditional testing with your doctor
can cost over a thousand dollars but
modern fertility is getting you the same
information at just 159 dollars which is
a fraction of the price and if you go to
modernfertility.com
toast you can get 20 off your test
you'll get inside insights into your
hormone levels how many eggs you have
other important fertility factors the
results go deep into what every hormone
means and you can also talk one-on-one
with a fertility nurse to review your
results and options for next steps if
you want kids today or maybe in the
future clinically sound info for your
body can help make sure make can help
you make the decision that's right for
you and right now modern fertility is
offering our listeners 20 off the test
when you go to modern fertility.com
toast that means your test will cost
only 139 instead of the several hundred
or even thousand plus dollars it could
cost at a doctor's office get 20 off
your fertility test when you go to
modern fertility.com toast
modernfertility.com
toast thank you claudia when it comes to
your fertility knowledge is power truly
our next story speaking of pop divas
kelly clarkson has been awarded her 10.4
million montana ranch in divorced win
kelly clarkson's estranged husband
brandon blackstock has to hand over the
keys to their montana ranch a judge
declared that the property belongs to
the 39 year old talk show host despite
the fact that he has been living there
since they split in june 2020. he
originally requested that the ranch was
marital property and should be shared
equally between the two but the judge
disagreed since it was clarkson who paid
the 10.4 million dollars for the
property
and you know what they say
actually queen kelly said it best
what doesn't kill you makes you
stronger
stronger
just me myself and i
what doesn't kill you makes you
stronger that's right
this little [ __ ] every time i get an
update on kelly clarkson divorce i want
to stick my elbow deeper into his throat
like what a little
leech get out of her home get out of her
everything yeah no beyond
judges
judge is like nope nope nope nope no
this judge is absolutely everything of
the sort like obviously is on our side
you know like understands that kelly
clarkson's a queen bee and kelly
clarkson fans since season one of
american idol saw everything that she
went through every piece by piece that
it took to get her to where she is and
she sees this man coming for the thing
she's put her blood sweat and tears too
and the judge is like no no and like
honestly we keep talking about how kelly
clarkson is like having this moment like
it's been it started like a year ago and
now she has the voice she's got the
kelly clarkson show which is such a
success like every celebrity's been
going on it she's so like this like warm
figure that everyone loves
and for him to like be trying to take a
piece of that away during he probably
knows how hard she's worked and how many
times she's like failed and not
succeeded and now it's like all paying
off and and for everything's coming up
kelly yeah and not brandon for someone
you used to like love and who knows you
so well to be like doing this during
i just it's unforgivable and i [ __ ]
hate this man
and if i ever see him in the streets
like it's on brandon blackstock it's
[ __ ] on yeah he's really like one of
the most hated men in america right now
literally him and brian laundry like
i [ __ ] hate this man he's such a i
don't even know the word is kaza yeah
but so like a mooch
leech
and justice for this judge like thank
you so much for you know
serving justice even though it is your
job yes but sometimes justice is not
served no and like
even though it is their job divorce
proceedings can go on for so long and
they're so tangled and you can even have
a prenup and all these documents like
and it just doesn't hold up so the fact
that like everything is being held up
that's because queen kelly has her [ __ ]
together yeah she has the right lawyers
she has the right attorney she has the
right managers she has it all together
he was her manager no i mean like
financial managers yeah yeah attorneys
and stuff like
she
has got it all
but he probably still you know what's so
disgusting about all this like he keeps
wanting from her like taking her house
the insane alimony but he also still
probably makes money off of her like on
deals when he was her manager like you
commissioned that until
perhaps
i wouldn't be surprised if he was like
yeah still cashing in deals that he was
negotiating on her behalf that are still
going on like yeah he might have been
her manager when she signed the keller
clarkson show yeah so he's still like in
perpetuity might make 10 off of that
until she renegotiates her contract oh i
can't even think about that i know it
would make me sick but you know what
like who's kelly gonna date like let's
play that game uh i think kelly's so
focused on herself right i know and her
kids and her career and like i feel like
kelly's like really one of the rare
people who's so fulfilled by her own
everything of the sortness yeah
but if we had to like who would we want
her with this is mambo yeah i kind of
like the country businessman beau like
she she was totally wrong brandon
blacksock is technically a businessman
no no i'm saying she wasn't totally
wrong in like her idea of like who she
should marry because like that was kind
of cute like reba's stepson you know
behind the cameras but like businessman
you know moving things chicken making
deals yeah no because he gets you get
too
caught up in everything and then you
have too much invested in her success
needs to be someone with a job that like
has nothing to do with the industry like
like a construction worker like just a
an
a nice
hard-working family-oriented man 100
that's what i wanted maybe one with kids
of his own like a blended family then
they could watch blended then they could
watch one and they'll have it all
figured out
it's a beautiful movie if you haven't
seen blended it's stunning you haven't
lived
are you ready for our next story yeah
it's really crazy casting shake up for
the show billions
i don't care no i think you'll make hair
even though you don't mind it's the guy
i'm like the main guy damian lewis is
leaving billions which is really crazy
because the show is about him is his
character gonna die or someone's just
gonna start playing him like nothing's
changed unclear no no no i don't think
they'll pull like a dynasty with a new
character player you know i kind of like
that like
we don't like why shake up the whole
show because one person decided to leave
yeah i don't know downton abbey they
should have done that about matthew no
that makes it a soap no no
because you can have create creativity
with the storyline but this does signal
the end of the show i really like the
show billions season six premieres in
january
and
damian lewis will not be a part of it he
is signed off on billions after a
five-season run as the alpha male hedge
fund billionaire bobby axelrod so this
show is over
um i don't know i wouldn't be so sure
it's a showtime show right yeah i don't
know when what's-her-face left uh
shameless it got so much better
really yeah i mean you know but like and
that's a hot take i think because she
was the [ __ ] worse but some people
liked her um there were so many they
spent tell me if billions is the same
actually they spent the whole
like first whatever seven seasons like
introducing you to so many characters on
shameless so you ended up loving and you
were like why are we focused on fiona
she [ __ ] sucks like okay you loved
do they do that do you love the other
characters no so okay right as it stands
like billions like this cat and mouse
game between damian lewis and paul
giamatti okay um if anybody should go it
should be paul giamatti like i hate his
character so [ __ ] much but i think
paul jamadi is one of the best actors no
he's too good of an actor and he was in
downton abbey he's too good of an actor
because i [ __ ] hate him
he's always playing a villain but you
know what in the like last few seasons
it's kind of tired they're either like
going for each other trying to destroy
each other's lives or they're teaming up
to like take someone else down but the
this variety article says that
production is underway with corey
stoll's character mike prince i believe
that's the person who played
peter rousseau in house of cards you
ever see it no
you haven't seen house of cards no i
don't support kevin spacey i mean i feel
that i watched it before i knew and then
i never finished it um yes i am correct
about that peter russo justice for him
by the way that's really important to
remember by the way you know what's so
crazy i was just doing like a trivia
thing do you know what the first ever
original show on netflix was
house of cards yeah is that crazy like
it is when you think about how far
they've come yes that is crazy so
anyways in the new season
mike prince who's played by cory still
will take center stage alongside chuck
road so i guess it'll be like and in the
show
yeah he's been like a billionaire coming
up who's really giving damian lewis a
run for his money so maybe he
successfully ran for his money and now
there's a new
there's new head honcho in town and
maybe like all you want to see from
damian lewis is like he literally has
everything that he continues to like
push the limit and push like the lines
of legality just like
be retired be satiated be satiated
so i started watching billions on delta
and they had the first five episodes and
it was so [ __ ] good and then this was
when i was on tour so like every time i
would get on the plane i would watch
another episode and then they like never
added more episodes so i was like i'm
done that's how i started watching too
and then i continued watching it's
honestly really good
and
that's gonna be crazy delta just
constantly pre like turning on premium
content like the only reason i ever saw
three identical strangers was because
delta had it you're lying i swear
oh my god i took the time to watch that
no it's literally like whoever's in
charge of choosing the content for the
delta portal delta studio i believe it's
called like kudos to you i one time
watch like the best [ __ ] sam smith
concert of my life on the plane like it
was like this random like
thing he filmed and they like bbc like
it was so [ __ ] good i was like
feeling inspired crying on the plane oh
how beautiful i was crying on the plane
yesterday of course you were because i
was crying
okay i'll tell you i was crying in the
uber
because i missed kayla so much and then
like my uber driver was really chatty so
i was like i had to stop crying like so
i could like talk would that make you
cry anymore yeah and then when i got on
the plane like it was all really just
like hitting me and i was putting on my
liked songs and it was like so many andy
grammer songs and i was like [ __ ] and it
was just it was over for me being with
the mask like no one could really see
sometimes you have to let it out
otherwise it's just if you try and stop
it's like damn no
it was it was so upsetting
damn i'm sorry at least you have a nice
trip to look forward to that's true you
know but i planned so poorly like i'm
going to the caribbean and i and i
should have just like
stayed in florida to like then go to the
caribbean like it was so stupid but
that's just me
yeah
okay ready for our fifth and final story
are you
oh you don't look ready no i'm not
because
it's the final story
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you for that our fifth and final
story is brought to you
by betterhelp is there something
interfering with your happiness or
preventing you from achieving your goals
betterhelp will assess your needs and
match you with your own licensed
professional therapist where you can
start communicating in under 48 hours
it's not a crisis line it's not
self-help it's professional therapy done
securely online you'll get timely and
thoughtful responses you can schedule
weekly video or phone sessions and you
won't ever have to sit in an
uncomfortable waiting room as you do
with traditional therapy betterhelp is
here to help you start living a happier
life today you can join the over 2
million people who have taken charge of
their mental health so many people have
done so that better help is recruiting
additional therapists in all 50 states
there's a special offer for the morning
toast listeners if you want to get 10
off your first month go to
betterhelp.com toast for percent off
your first month that's better h-e-l-p
dot com slash toast
thank you claudia our fifth and final
story some crazy media news that if
you're not tuned into you really should
because it's some of the craziest stuff
i've heard cmn crazy media news we don't
get it a lot no um but then you hear a
story like this and you're like oh we
should hear about this more because it
makes a lot of sense so aussie media is
not shutting down after all ceo carlos
watson says what is aussie media aussie
media is like one of those just like
content sites that's like
i mean not that i
have ever gone to aussie media unless
they were like running like a dot-com
yeah yeah unless they were running like
ads in the background and trying to get
like cheap clicks for their website
using that shady third party um
advertisers okay ozy ozy so it's a
website i believe that's like a content
farm you know there are so many of these
websites some of them are
more popular than others yeah a modern
media company they have podcasts news
they've gotten many awards okay yeah so
last week an article came out about
aussie media that pretty much like just
showed it for the house of cards that it
is basically it started with um they
were gonna be acquired or
[Music]
yeah acquired or bought or whatever by
goldman sachs and they were goldman
sachs was like going through
their
financial financials and also just like
who they are what they are what they
have how many listeners subscribers
everything
readers and on the call was meant to be
a youtube
uh
a a person high up at youtube who was
going to like attest to the fact that
the their youtube is really [ __ ]
popping oh okay so so that they could
show goldman sachs yeah like our even
youtube says like are you kidding it's
really impressive yeah and on this call
the person from youtube like at the last
minute wants it to be a voice call not
as like a zoo not a zoom with cameras
and towards the end of the call they're
like their voice is sort of cutting out
it as if they're it's using like a
voicethread changer
and it turns out that someone within the
aussie media company posed as a youtube
rep a youtube rep
and in order to get on the call and like
sell through ozzy to goldman sachs like
fraud
um and goldman sachs like figured it out
and even the email they set up to like
loop in the youtube guide was like a
fake email
so it started this whole like window
into like aussie media is lying about
like their numbers they're this and like
even with their youtube channel well i
wanted to look at their youtube they
have a few videos that have over a
million views but like majority of them
don't
the likes to comments ratio is is bad
have they taken down their youtube
channel because i can't find it and the
only thing coming up is everyone talking
about oh that's the downfall of aussie
media so funny inside aussie media's
downfall carlos watson live so
oh that all the telltale signs of like
[ __ ] which you know what like and i
feel like there are so many media
companies and just like
uh publishers in general like their
numbers their numbers and it's like so
he says they have millions of
subscribers for their newsletter and all
these things and like you can pay to get
emails to purchase emails to purchase
emails i get so much crapola because
someone sold my information i'm that
doesn't make me a reader of ozzie so
much crapola
so it's really this interesting
case study yes it is a [ __ ]
fraudulence and inflated numbers and
like and yes you know if you're going to
get bought by a big company like you're
showing some vanity first you want to
show yourself you're showing forward
you're showing impressions overviews
yeah you know it's we know the tricks
yeah but like this was like completely
fabricated no and that's like the weird
thing right now about like living in the
digital ages there's so many companies
like media companies and just like
digitally based companies who are so
fraudulent and like they're valued at
like 100 million dollars and they
literally like okay i don't know how or
why but like their instagrams and their
tick tocks and their youtubes have
millions of subscribers and you go to a
video and there's six thousand views
like yeah yeah it's so fraudulent and
it's so crazy to me that like these huge
financial institutions like goldman
sachs these big like banks and
whatever investment like um
hedge funds are like spending all this
money and like just get your intern to
look at their instagram and they'll let
you know if this is a fraudulent company
not even that has your intern ever heard
of this company i never heard an article
about aussie media someone was like
saying like they'll tell you how they're
everywhere and they're doing everything
but i've actually never encountered
aussie media in a natural way no this is
the first i'm hearing i believe they
have something called aussie fest which
is
a real thing and that's like
popular popular
but how much were they going to be
acquired for i don't know i bet it was
like literally a billion dollars and no
one's ever heard of this company that's
what's so fraudulent about like the
digital age and i think like all these
banks that are like filled with old
people just like want to be current
they're like oh you have a million
followers on tick tock let me buy that
from you yeah that just ain't how it
works goldman yeah and then how it works
mr sax it's really true even like so i
guess this carlos watson he was like
gonna do a talk show
on the aussie youtube channel
um and i remember seeing ads for it
around the city and really there was
like quotes on the buses that were like
the biggest show in late night and i was
like wow i'm really i'm really off
because i've never seen this before by
the way what i've learned is that
pretty much every billboard you see for
a tv show is going to call itself like
the number one show in late night and
that's because in one particular
demographic yes last week tonight with
john oliver is number one amongst you
know 27 to 29 year old men so everyone
is allowed to call themselves legally
the number one show because in once with
people who can't find the remote you are
number one like no but like or even i
think that's even giving them too much
credit like in one category like if i
sit here and say the morning toast is
the number one show it is
well that's yeah because it's because it
is that's like not fair no i know what
you're saying what's like a show no use
the toast example i know what you're
saying if i say the morning toast is the
number one show we could go around eggs
and say the more chosen is the number
one show and then somewhere on the
bottom it's like because someone said
that once right but yes they do but i
was just like wow even though factually
you look on the charts we're like number
11 not number one
still pretty good but you know what i'm
saying yes yes but no it's like or if
that one time we went to number one
which by the way we've only made it to
number two because of felonious florida
yes yes oh my god [ __ ] fellows when
we like were like first launching our
show we were at number two in the
podcast store which is unheard of and
there was this other show that launched
at the same time
and by the way have you ever heard of
felonious florida ever after that no no
but it was just like having a moment and
we could not beat them
yeah [ __ ] felonious florida king
felonious florida anyways so carlos
watson i guess he had said that they
were gonna like you know after the
charade was called for what it was he
said they were gonna close but now on
nbc on the today show he said we're open
for business this is our lazarus moment
if you will
this is so embarrassing like this is so
embarrassing isn't it illegal people are
comparing it's illegal to like flip
youtube stuff oh yes like youtube's now
launching an investigation because like
their security was breached there's
someone pretending to be a high level
youtube rep but also um like flubbing
your numbers like this when you're like
trying to get rid i remember watching
the wework documentary and like that was
what made the whole thing illegal yes
they're lying about the numbers yes so
people are like comparing this to
theranos which is on trial
right like there's an element of
illegality here correct yeah but i also
think like this is just
one of many i think so too you know when
you hear about all these media companies
that get bought for billions of dollars
and then like it's just so fraudulent
and they have like no [ __ ] influence
period they have no audience they're
literally like they're only paying
customers are people who have literally
died like
yeah it's
it's like them having so like i think
with aussie media what happened is they
raised so much money like under this
like a fundraising for this idea of
aussie media so they had a lot of money
to spend and they bought and they bought
like
i don't want to say they bought like
followers and stuff but you can buy
someone's subscriber list yeah it's like
really a kosher way of making followers
legal um and so it's all just like this
house of cards based on all this money
that they raised yet nobody gave a [ __ ]
about ozzie right at the end of the day
like you can raise all the money you
want you can buy all the subscribers you
want but if you don't have an audience
you don't have an audience and no amount
of money can fix that yeah
we have an audience through that we do
but we
raise no money yeah
are you looking for a new investment
call we are very much available and open
to the idea of having a new studio at
the goldman sachs hq imagine we have
like different financial analysts on and
we'd interview them like no and every
time a celebrity was single we'd say
businessman bow oh yeah get over there
people have a conveyor
um okay so that is a crazy story and
those were our stories those were our
stories i feel as though you needed to
know them now for a little tv recap
before the housewives i wanted to talk
to you about snl because i watched the
season premiere with casey musgraves as
a performer and
owen wilson as the opener his
both of his brothers were there i didn't
know there was a third one luke was like
smiling it was so cute like very cute
and luke was actually in um a sketch a
sketch not a live one but they did this
like star trek battle of the egos where
all these billionaires are going to
space to like you know whose dick is
bigger and
bezos was played by owen wilson
someone from essendo played um richard
branson he looked so much like him
that's an easy one to dress up yeah yeah
and then um
someone played elon musk and oh luke i
get some confused was just in there like
you know okay doing something okay cool
um
but i want to talk about the sketches
they it was so bad like it was literally
i didn't like laugh at all olivia fell
asleep like it was really really bad
which is crazy just for a season opener
um the three new people two of them were
in a bunch of sketches and i don't
remember their names but they were
pretty good like
they were trying harder than any of the
other cast members have tried in years
because they were so excited like it's
their first time and they like nailed
every single line which nobody on snl
does it's so frustrating like luke
wilson
wait oh win oh and i'm getting that
confused owen like flubbed so many of
his lines but you know what i learned
that i did not know that i'm not sure if
you knew do you know that owen wilson
the reason why he's like so irrelevant
he made so much money he was the voice
of lightning mcqueen in cars cars one
two and three
like no wonder why he's just like
low-key that's what his monologue was
about like i've been known to be like
low energy and like not care about
anything well you made a hundred million
dollars doing cars i wouldn't care about
anything either cars is like one of the
biggest franchises and they did a sketch
about lightning mcqueen where like
lightning mcqueen becomes this like very
non-pc like racist like car and he's
like i'm not doing this like i care so
much about the legacy of lightning
mcqueen and then he like saw his disney
contract and he was like i'll do it but
like he kept flubbing the lines like
the r word was in there like 400 times
and he like wouldn't say it he just kept
flubbing the lines it was a really funny
concept but very poorly executed oh
it was just it really was not good and
then
like the saving grace was casey
um
and i haven't really spoken about it
because it really paint like i
discovered casey musk grapes like i will
literally we know i will to the death
defend like my queen
but this era
is just not my particular favorite i'll
say that and
i'm struggling like i really am like
i like the beat but it's just
it's not for me so
with love and respect what did she
perform
justified which to me like is the the
best song on the album but if it was on
golden hour it would have been the worst
out the worst song on the album like
that's in my opinion what the level of
musicality is is and then camera roll
which is just not good okay so here's my
thing and camera roll is tough for me
because it keeps getting stuck in my
head um
but with so many songs on the album we
were listening to one this morning i
think my least favorite one is simple
times just because the lyrics are very
like 12 year old girl like i'm going to
the mall with my friends like liter that
literal like yes i miss seeing my
friendly agree and spending time
together we would have the best time so
like for me what's always set casey moss
graves apart is her ability to like
to write lyrics so poetically they fit
perfectly in every groove of every man
everything's like a metaphor like yes
follow your arrow if she wrote that for
star cross it would say be yourself
literally so i completely agree i think
that that like poetic element is just
missing and she's being very literal
like a song called camera roll is just
like so not casey like it should have
been called like photographic memory
like you know whatever she would have
done like yeah i i'm just not into this
era like no at all the song camera which
i i actually like because it's getting
stuck in my head so i don't want to pass
you but it's like
chronological order like thinking yes
that's our camera yeah we know that's
how camera roll works chronological
order
nothing but torture that sounds actually
pretty good but like there's just it's
just not my favorite and
yeah that's i'll just leave it at that
that song is like an it's just an ad for
iphone
literally use it totally like an apple
commercial yeah so click on your albums
and you can do that
no literally it's just not
for me don't sort by the faces is that
how it's is that the layer no but like
that's what she's saying yeah so did you
know you could use maps she didn't save
snl in the way that i thought she was is
what i was gonna say
are you okay yeah it's just really funny
no it's just not good that's what i've
been feeling about the album i've still
been listening to it just because um i
like it now i like a work a body of work
while i'm getting ready or something
instead of like jumping through all my
leg songs so i have been experiencing it
and there are and i like star-crossed
the song more than you did
um i know people are liking breadwinner
yeah well it just went like viral on
tech talk so people don't even know the
song they just know that one part
because they're like when you are
jamming to the song but you make you
know a dollar an hour like he wants a
breadwinner
that sounds fine like i don't know i
just feel like
usually like i cannot be pulled away
from a casey album i have to spend hours
decoding what she means
and i just don't feel that way about
this album yeah and i thought she would
like save the snl episode and honestly
it was just like the whole thing was
just a waste of time honestly
damn okay
i'm sorry to hear that
but i want him
what kim is coming this week i know and
you know what like i'm gonna be like
without
service like i'm not gonna be able to
watch like i don't know how i'm gonna
stay actually i said i stay up pretty
late i'm so excited this is so [ __ ]
late it's so late it's crazy but kim
is going to be so incredible and
halsey's so great i love her sure kim
i just
i'm really i ca i haven't been this
excited since elon elon yeah no it's
really good i'm so surprised that this
wasn't the opener
you know maybe kim was busy you saw that
she had dinner with kanye
they went on a double date with the
romulus's no i didn't tracy tracy and
ron i didn't see ron romulus that's a
tough name yeah they went to nobu malibu
ron mielis and of course they did yeah
love to see it you do love to see did
you see parents reconnecting or just
co-parenting in a healthy way
either way happy for them um okay that i
want to just really quickly talk to you
about housewives i don't want to spoil
anything for you but both episodes were
so good like potomac was just twisted
like they got to this house and like
robin and gizelle are like we're not
coming you invited us in a rude way
we're like okay bye like
so i think i think they thought everyone
would be like no please come everyone's
like okay like no one cares yeah um the
husbands came not everyone uh
came some of them are coming later
michael's not coming at all and karen's
husband is coming a day later so
some of the guys were there mia's
husband like is just a little wild like
that survived that yeah and like i
really just want to defend him because
like
everyone's just like coming for mia but
he was acting like an animal but they
just get there and wendy's like feeding
everyone shots so like by the time
ashley and karen show up last they're
like all [ __ ] wasted like especially
mia and wendy
so things obviously get really heated
between wendy i mean between mia and
candace because
she just kept keeps bringing up mia's
mom like they're fighting about nonsense
and then she's like your mom is low
budget your almost ratchet your mom is
broke [ __ ] like yeah and it's just so
and they and wendy has been trying to
tell candace like to stop at the mom
stuff because you don't know what she's
been through like
but candace won't even listen she's just
like mom mom mom and you know what like
maybe i thought mia was wrong in the
beginning but now i don't even care like
it's so
candice is so below the belt she makes
it so unenjoyable to watch because you
can't even get on her side at all
because once you start your mom's broke
[ __ ] your mom is low budget she said it
multiple times last night and the
episode before it was just so
frustrating like so frustrating she's
indefensible and yet she gets away with
all every terrible behavior
and even though i was turned like i was
coming to i was making peace with my
penis um it just brings you back to the
monique stuff yeah of course and she and
by the way you know you saw the scene
where like mia throws lettuce of course
yeah
who threw the first piece of lettuce
candace can't she threw one piece and
then mia was like [ __ ] that and threw
the whole platter good because candace
was just like go back to your pimp you
[ __ ] like she was really going so
[ __ ] below the belt
what in the world and she just like
can't get over the fact that like mia
and her husband met at a strip club and
like i don't know i first of all who
[ __ ] cares like to each their own two
like me it's not like mia was hiding
that and like they all found out and
they're like me was like yeah and and
then her husband was like yeah mia still
loves to go to the strip clubs we go
together like i don't know it's not what
i would do but i appreciate the
confidence like a hundred percent
candace is just like so jealous like
everyone and everything mental
small-minded like i can't believe she
gets away with that agreed like she's
she's so condescending like it was just
a frustrating episode because candace
was acting like an animal of course
robin and gisele end up coming next week
you know like their big protest is over
um
and things obviously get even more
heated but what i did love was that
wendy gave everyone like a list she said
karen and ashley no karen and um osa
what's her name scala
karen and escala you get to choose rooms
first because we were put in the cottage
and then ashley you can choose the next
room because you know you left your kids
at home and like we still are we're so
happy you're here and we just want you
to be comfortable and she went online
and then she was like and candace you
can choose last who said this wendy
because it's her trip it's her trip and
she shoved wendy into the cottage at the
last trip and yeah which is weird
because wendy and candace are close yeah
but so wendy was like [ __ ] that but no
they are close and you know what their
husbands are close to like seeing the
husbands
how they interact wendy's husband and
chris are really good friends
interesting
i'm glad the husbands are there that
always makes it interesting
me too
it was a good episode but salt lake city
was so good like we picked back up at
the ice fishing where like they jen
basically like is talking to stuart and
she's like it's just gonna a fake
apologize to make it go and like
meredith is like
not believing it which is everything in
the sort whatever it was done but then
we meet this new woman
angie i didn't even know we were getting
a new woman and she meets up with lisa i
remember that girl sarah jane who like
keeps almost becoming a housewife like
she was on last season she's friends
with lisa she's blonde
maybe so whatever like they just
steamrolled over her and writing to
angie who was like this fabulous woman
who discovered that she's cousins with
whitney because they're all related to
the pioneers and lisa's like so jealous
that her friend of like you know i think
like six or ten years is becoming
friends with whitney but like their
cousins and they really like each other
like what's the problem
so
basically angie's having this party at
her house it's like this fabulous casino
themed fundraiser for um
an organization called the in circle
they her and her husband have a son
who's transgender and it's like an
organization for
you know a safe place for it was really
beautiful like the whole thing and the
husband got choked up talking about like
they left the mormon church because like
it's so
unwelcoming to their son and it was just
like it was actually really beautiful
and there was a guy there who donated a
million dollars like it was a swanky
affair like this woman angie is bringing
us everything she had a costume change
her house was beautiful it was gorgeous
but what had happened was that she had
sat down with lisa and said that she
invited whitney and heather to her gala
and then five hours later the caterer
for the gala who's really good friends
with lisa call germans like we can't do
it anymore we spoke to lisa's assistant
and we can't do it that's what they said
verbatim like lisa's assistant called us
we cannot do your event anymore. so then
angie goes out to lunch with whitney and
she's like do you think like she's like
sabotaging my event because like i
invited you guys
and it does sound really stupid but like
they did write in the email that lisa's
assistant called them and that's why
they have to cancel yeah so
everyone's having fun at the party jen
and mary are even talking mary's just
like so understands jen for who she is
and she's not bothering to get into it
but then angie pulls lisa over and it's
like i got this email from the caterer
and they said that they spoke to your
assistant and then they canceled like
what the [ __ ] and lisa is just like
freaking out like literally screaming
crying like
uh and then for some reason she brings
meredith and jen shaw into it because
the point is basically lisa's mad that
her friend angie's friends with whitney
but what she's doing right now between
meredith and jen is the exact same
[ __ ] thing right and it's so
hypocritical she starts like crying
freaking screaming out she's so wrong
she's getting caught in something i
don't know what she did with the caterer
but she's acting so guilty so then of
course whitney's so drunk whitney comes
in and just like sits down and lisa's
like what are you doing here she's like
well and she's my friend i want to make
sure she's okay
and they just go off she's screaming
crying i want john and i want john and
remember how like meredith was like
freaking out rightfully so at the gen
shock conversation at ice fishing and
lisa would not let her leave like when
she was really just clearly wanted to
get out of there yeah they wouldn't let
lisa leave and it was so everything of
the story because she got caught in some
lie i'm not sure what it is but she got
so caught she was looking so guilty like
crying like like a two-year-old like oh
over here like it was so amazing and
whitney really didn't even say anything
she just like sat there and watched but
lisa is so triggered by the presence of
whitney like i don't get that at
all are so like harmless
and the beef between them doesn't run
very deep it's not that serious i can
just tell you what it is personality
differences so they go to lunch next
week as do as do jen shaw and brooks
because she said to meredith like i'll
apologize to brooks okay yeah but so
then like basically what
what jen shaw did to meredith she also
did to mary like basically mary was like
we made up at the reunion and then she
posted this really mean meme and then
they showed the beam and it was like a
picture of like i don't know if it was
mary but like a picture of a young girl
and her grandfather like
and it was like when you order no no it
was like just a meme and then next to it
was mary and her husband like basically
like you married your grandfather like
right after they had made up
so
mary actually didn't really get into it
i think that she doesn't want to like
keep dragging like she just is like
hates jen but like like is civil with
her yeah which is really the smart way
to handle someone like jeff yeah
especially since jen will probably be
out of the picture soon yeah hopefully
so all in all it was a good episode
heather was like so irrelevant um and
it's so crazy because like
with this gen shot thing i know i'm
going to turn on heather because like
the fact that she's sticking up for jen
shaw is so losery and also watching that
episode last week where she just like
groveled in that ice cube like it was so
illusory and i'm like hating lisa right
now but knowing how she like immediately
turns on jen like i think i'm gonna have
a huge and when i was watching lisa with
these two new girls angie and sarah like
talk about how much they love kfc i'm
like i just wish lisa could be like this
all the time like there are qualities of
lisa that i actually really like i agree
and so i'm holding out hope me too but
like she needs to get off of whitney and
heather like it's not a thing no she
needs to get off gen cha and she does
yes that too but like it's so mean to
meredith a meredith was looking oh my
god at this event
so unbelievably gorgeous like i never
saw an outfit so gorgeous in my life wow
i'm really excited to watch i think i'm
gonna watch today i was very much
looking forward to it i just had my
reading priorities that needed to take
precedence it was a good episode the
salt lake city was better than potomac
but um and then the other thing i
watched is squid game which is this show
it's
it's a korean show it's like number one
in every country in the world and
everyone's talking about it people were
like doing the squid games challenge on
tick tock so i was like let me see me
let me started it we were so confused
but it's immediately became very good
and it is a like a hunger games type of
show i would say yeah um
and it's in korean but they have like
english dubbed over it but then they
also have subtitles that don't match the
english
dubbing and it was very confusing so i
ended up watching without subtitles and
just listening to the english jumped
over which was fine
um and it was good it was really good
the ending was so [ __ ] atrocious and
i think they're setting us up for a
second season which i'm if it had just
ended completely and like it was a
mini-series i think it would have been
great a limited series sorry not a mini
series but the ending like really
bothered me and i thought the show was
good up until then there were a lot of
really good characters and just
something new you know i never watched
anything new yeah it was good i'm happy
i think i think you'd like it and i know
zack would like it a lot oh i'll tell
him yeah um so yeah i really watched a
lot of tv this weekend because i was
like on like
taylor time on kayla time yeah
when she's allowed when she's allowed
okay well
thank you for summing it up for us
it's a pleasure
and we will see you tomorrow thank you
guys so much for listening to the
morning toast the millennium morning
show where we deliver the fast life
stories that you need to know every
monday through friday on youtube so if
you're watching this on youtube please
feel free to subscribe give this video a
thumbs up we're also available as
podcasts anywhere podcasts can be found
so it's a spotify itunes stitch or
public radio i have already kind of
blocked all the places where we listen
to the podcast find out some more until
sleep five star you about a beautiful
stunning and smart we are and if you
made it to the end of this episode
congratulations you are now a part of
the society season two full of people
who only listen to the end of the
episode because they are true toasters
and to let us know that you've made it
to the end of the episode why don't you
go drop a comment on our most recent
instagram make it the emoji siren the
siren emoji to commemorate the greatest
siren of all time of all time have a
great day everyone we'll see you
tomorrow bye